this next comic is gonna be your new
favorite please give
a warm banana moist welcome to
hello hello hello thank you so much for
having me
i am dwayne perkins wow
2020 was a crazy year and 2021 is just
right after it just giving the same kind
of energy so i've been just
really focused on self-care that has
been my thing
i have to because existing is
exhausting and i wish that we had like
the ability to just have like
tiny little voluntary temporary comas
uh and we just like relax and chill then
we wake up refreshed ready to take on
the day i just realized
i was just dramatically describing naps
that is what a nap
is just a tiny small coma that you wake
up from
uh you know what but i just you know i i
want them to be
a little harder i want to sleep a little
deeper that's
pretty much what my whole quarantine has
been
naps and tv and also dressing like i'm
at a resort about to do a cover of mambo
number five
there's just been a lot of tv lots and
lots of tv lots of netflix
um did you know by the way that netflix
was ran
by this algorithm there's an algorithm
that dictates
the kind of cover art it shows you
depending on the demographic it thinks
you are and because i am
a black man who watches lots of black
themes they tailor the art for that so
for the show sabrina which is about um a
white
witch the cover art on my netflix menu
is
of a black witch named prudence she is a
great character
on the show but the show is called
sabrina
and then for a show like the office
the cover art is just stanley the
black sassy man
then on the cover art for a show like
friends it just says haha boy stop
playing
i can't go back on that show um
oh i've also been watching a lot of
disney plus i am a disney girl
of disney so much uh and there has been
a lot of
discussion about the disney princesses
in the zeitgeist
but there has not been enough discourse
about the disney princes
who are um not great let me tell you uh
so i
been re-watching a lot of disney movies
and let me just go through a couple
um take prince philip from uh
sleeping beauty he traveled thousands of
miles
he fought a dragon dragon a fire
breathing dragon
just so he can kiss a girl in a coma he
did not know
problematic that is problematic it is
that's just what it is
um take a aladdin uh
street rat homeless he found a genie
lamp he was uh granted the powers to
make three wishes and he could have
wished for anything he could have wished
for the
end of homelessness unless he was
homeless but what did he wish for he
wished to become a prince
because that was the only way he could
get with princess jasmine
toxic and malignant don't like it don't
like it
and lastly take um prince eric from the
little mermaid
he murdered an octopus woman of color
and for what so that he can be with a
girl
who did not have a voice and literally
could not say no
cancel he's canceled prince eric is
cancelled
disney none of these princes aren't good
role models but
i did find one who
to me represented the future
um let's step into a little film named
mulan
uh mulan decided that she had to go into
the army
to uh save her family's honor and she uh
cosplayed as a man uh and there was a
a a young man by the name of lee shang
who
despite her gender he was like you know
what
you're the one i love because he was
going off vibes vibes alone
and that is the future he is the role
model for all of us thank you so much
i gotta watch that set again let's
rewind the banana more
stage is lucky to have that one i'll
tell ya
oh what a treat